mindfulness is really the practice of
being aware of what's going on in the
moment
some people add you know without judging
it so just really observing and then the
practice of meditation is a more you
know kind of structured disciplined
practice often with some kind of an
anchor where you're resting attention
the breath or something like that
in some specific conditions the evidence
is a little bit stronger on the effects
of mindfulness meditation and those are
depression anxiety and chronic pain
the idea behind mindfulness based
cognitive therapy is that by training
people in mindfulness meditation we
increase their capacity for inter
reception and for being able to listen
to their body so to speak and to drop in
the body and that will actually help
them disengage from this cognitive
rumination with negative thoughts about
self
we're testing these hypotheses in the
brain by looking at the brain networks
that are involved and having people do
specific tasks in the scanner to test if
they engage in these tests differently
after having received the mindfulness
training
the purpose of this research is to find
out the mechanisms of mindfulness
training in the brain and from that
information hopefully make some changes
to the intervention that take those
mechanisms into account for example
doing more of certain types of practices
if we think these are the ones that are
key and perhaps doing less of other
aspects of the mindfulness training if
science finds that these elements don't
actually have so much of an impact I
think you kind of have this daily
practice so that as you go about your
day you're able to be mindful and
present or notice when you're not
because it's nobody does it 100%